bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de la sincérité
je suis tombé il y a quelques temps sur
un petit livre de Jacques etlude un
livre de moins de 100 pages qui
s'intitule je suis sincère avec moi-même
et autres lieux communs
et ce titre a éveillé ma curiosité parce
que je me suis dit tiens voilà un auteur
qui considère que se dire sincère avec
soi-même serait un lieu commun
autrement dit qui sous-entend que nous
ne serions pas vraiment sincère avec
nous-mêmes
qu'il s'agirait là d'une phrase toute
faite mais qui ne correspondrait pas à
la réalité
donc j'ai voulu en savoir plus j'ai lu
le texte de Jacques Ulule et son propos
m'a semblé suffisamment pertinent et
suffisamment à contre-courant pour me
donner envie d'y consacrer un épisode
alors d'abord quelques mots sur l'auteur
Jacques etule donc Jacques cellule est
un sociologue français du 20e siècle
assez difficile à classer parce qu'il
est à la fois chrétien et marxiste
d'ailleurs son christianisme mais
lui-même assez difficile à classer
puisque Jacques elûle est un chrétien
qui considère que le christianisme est
en fait une trahison du Christ
c'est pas banal
et même en tant que marxiste élu l'a
toujours gardé une distance critique à
l'égard du marxisme en disant qu'il
s'agissait d'une idéologie comme une
autre et en se montrant très critique à
l'égard de l'URSS et des militants
communistes
donc on a affaire ici un penseur
atypique un penseur qui ne rentre pas
dans les cases
et vous allez voir que le texte dont on
va parler aujourd'hui illustre bien ce
caractère atypique et anticonformiste
par ailleurs jacquelule a beaucoup
travaillé sur les questions liées à la
technique et aux modifications que la
technique a entraîné sur l'homme
contemporain
il pense que l'individu contemporain
c'est soumis à la logique technicienne
et l'une de ces idées maîtresses c'est
que contrairement à ce qu'on entend
souvent l'homme n'aime pas la liberté
l'homme n'éprouve pas un désir de
liberté
mais il éprouve plutôt un désir de
sécurité et un désir de conformité
ça c'est très important le désir de
conformité parce que depuis l'expérience
de 1000 g on sait que l'être humain a
tendance à se conformer à l'autorité
mais ce que dit elule c'est que non
seulement l'être humain se conforme à
l'autorité mais surtout qu'il n'aime pas
la liberté
on rejoint ici l'idée de Sartre qui
disait que l'être humain fuyait la
liberté parce qu'il en avait peur
la liberté nous fait peur parce que la
liberté nous rend responsable de chacun
de nos actes
et c'est pour ça que Jacques etule
établit une distinction absolument
fondamentale entre deux types de liberté
la liberté prétexte et la liberté réelle
qu'est-ce que la liberté prétexte c'est
la liberté
d'assouvir ses penchants les plus bas
de se laisser aller à ses pulsions
et vous voyez que quand on dit ça comme
ça se laisser aller on voit bien que le
mot liberté n'est pas du tout adapté
se laisser aller ce n'est pas être libre
parce que se laisser aller c'est une
attitude passive
être libre ce n'est pas être passif
c'est même exactement le contraire
être libre c'est être capable de ne pas
suivre ces penchants naturels
c'est être capable de dire non
on trouvait déjà cette idée chez les
stoïciens les stoïciens pour qui la
liberté c'était la capacité qu'à l'être
humain de maîtriser ses passions
passions passif
la liberté ce n'est pas un relâchement
la liberté c'est un effort
et c'est là qu'on va pouvoir comprendre
ce que nous dit jacquelule à propos de
la sincérité puisque c'est là qu'on
était parti et notamment du fait de se
dire sincère avec soi-même
ce que nous dit Jacqueline c'est que
quand on dit qu'on est censé avec
soi-même il s'agit en réalité d'une
stratégie
d'une stratégie pour présenter comme une
qualité morale ce qui est en réalité une
marque d'égoïsme
être sincère avec soi-même ce serait
tout simplement
justifier de succomber à ses penchants
les plus bas
alors on va prendre le temps d'expliquer
tout ça
déjà il faut commencer par dire que le
titre de ce texte je suis sincère avec
moi-même est un titre un peu trompeur
parce qu'en réalité Jacques et lul ne
parle pas seulement du fait d'être
sincère avec soi-même
il parle aussi et même surtout du fait
d'être sincère avec les autres
alors quelle est la différence
être sincère avec soi-même ça pose la
question du déni
ça pose la question de l'auto
aveuglement
et de ce que Sartre appelait la
translucidité de la conscience
translucide ça veut dire qu'il laisse
passer la lumière
c'est une image pour dire se voir tel
que l'on est
autrement dit savoir qui l'on est
et c'est pas évident de savoir qu'il en
est
on part souvent du principe qu'on se
connaît bien qu'on est même le mieux
placé pour se connaître mais ce n'est
pas aussi simple
déjà parce que nous ne sommes plus
exactement aujourd'hui la même personne
qui est
nous évoluons nous évoluons constamment
et il y a parfois un décalage entre ce
que nous sommes et la conscience de ce
que nous sommes
mais aussi parce que nous lisons pas en
nous comme dans un livre ouvert
il y a toujours une part d'opacité dans
notre vie intérieure
l'introspection le fait de regarder à
l'intérieur de soi c'est difficile
et souvent ce que nous sommes ce mélange
avec ce que nous croyons être
ou avec ce que nous voulons être
vous savez il y a des tas de magazines
dans lesquels on vous fait faire des
tests de personnalité
pour soi-disant apprendre à mieux se
connaître
quel genre d'ami êtes-vous
êtes-vous quelqu'un de fiable
quel métier est fait pour vous
sauf que ce qu'on oublie c'est que pour
que ces tests est une pertinence
encore faut-il qu'on sache réellement ce
qu'on pense
encore faut-il qu'on parle de soi et non
pas de l'image qu'on s'est construite de
soi
et ça c'est compliqué
savoir qui on est c'est pas aussi simple
que regarder par la fenêtre pour savoir
s'il pleut
on peut se convaincre qu'on est
quelqu'un de fiable de généreux
d'altruiste parce qu'on se sera
construit sur cette image
parce qu'on a besoin d'une
représentation mentale de nous-mêmes qui
nous sied
pour ne pas dire qui nous arrange
quand on fait quelque chose de mal on ne
se dit pas qu'on a fait quelque chose de
mal
on se dit qu'on a fait ce qu'on a pu
on a fait moins mal que les autres
on se dit qu'on a fait quelque chose de
bien mais que ce sont les autres qui
n'ont pas compris
en psychologie cognitive on appelle ça
le biais d'auto complaisance
le biais d'autocomplaisance c'est ce
mécanisme qui consiste à toujours
trouver des justifications à ce qu'on
pense ou à ce qu'on fait alors qu'on ne
trouverait pas de justification s'il
s'agissait de quelqu'un d'autre
à fortiori de quelqu'un qu'on aime pas
il est rare qu'on se définisse comme
quelqu'un d'ingrat
quelqu'un d'égoïste
ça peut arriver mais c'est rare
et ça des notes pour le coup une
certaine honnêteté vis-à-vis de soi-même
et même un certain courage
une capacité à ne pas être affecté par
le jugement d'autrui
mais dans la plupart des cas la
sincérité avec soi-même à ses limites
les limites de nos besoins
psychologiques en termes d'image de soi
donc quand on répond à un test de
personnalité il est fréquent qu'on
réponde davantage à ce qu'on pense être
voir à ce qu'on voudrait être plutôt
qu'à ce qu'on est vraiment
dans le premier cas cela vient du fait
que nous ne sommes pas translucides à
nous-mêmes
que nous ne sommes pas toujours
clairvoyant sur nous-même
c'est le fameux connais-toi toi-même
Chara Socrate
dans le deuxième cas cela vient du fait
que nous sommes soumis à un impératif
psychologique de maintien d'une image de
soi positive
donc à ce stade du raisonnement on
pourrait se dire que la sincérité envers
soi-même c'est impossible
parce que ça suppose une clairvoyance et
une objectivité qui n'est pas accessible
à l'être humain
nous ne sommes pas des êtres analytiques
nous sommes des êtres émotionnels
affectif sensible
et on a beau se croire sincère avec
soi-même le fait est que notre sincérité
est dépendante de notre perception
la perception
c'est subjectif
mais admettons
admettons qu'on puisse se percevoir tel
que l'on est
admettons qu'il n'y ait pas tous ces
problèmes d'opacité de la conscience de
soi
et qu'on puisse réellement se concevoir
tel qu'on est
ce que nous dit Jacqueline c'est que le
fait de se dire sincère avec soi-même
c'est d'abord un moyen de justifier le
fait de ne faire aucun effort
c'est d'abord un moyen de légitimer
notre égoïsme et notre absence de prise
en considération de l'autre
on va prendre un exemple assez connu
c'est un exemple un peu caricatural mais
ça illustre assez bien ce que je cherche
à dire Jacques pilule c'est la parabole
du médecin
supposons que vous soyez médecin qu'un
patient vient de vous voir et que les
analyses révèlent qu'il est atteint d'un
cancer
et que selon toute vraisemblance il n'en
a plus que pour quelques mois
je dis selon toute vraisemblance parce
que par définition l'avenir est toujours
un certain
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
est-ce que vous allez lui dire
monsieur je vous annonce que vous allez
mourir dans trois mois
mais si vous vous trompez
si la personne guérit
et puis surtout quel sera l'effet de
cette annonce
est-ce que ça va aider votre passion
est-ce que ça va le mettre dans les
meilleures dispositions pour affronter
la maladie
c'est compliqué
parce que d'un côté on a la vérité
et d'un autre côté on a la conséquence
de cette vérité la conséquence de
l'annonce de cette vérité
qui est encore plus lourde que cette
vérité elle-même
alors ici il y a deux écoles
l'école déontologiste on dit toute la
vérité et on se moque des conséquences
et l'école conséquentialiste
on dit ce qu'il faut pour que la
personne aille le moins mal possible
en Europe continentale la tradition
philosophique est plutôt d'inspiration
déontologiste
on préfère la vérité aux conséquences de
la vérité
en Grande-Bretagne aux États-Unis on est
plutôt conséquentialiste le résultat
avant tout
ce que dit Jacqueline ce n'est pas qu'il
faut cacher la vérité
c'est que dire la vérité telle qu'elle
est la vérité toute crue
c'est faire preuve d'une absence de
compassion à l'égard d'autrui
personne ne se dira publiquement contre
la vérité
personne ne prône le mensonge
mais il y a une différence entre prenez
la vérité prenez la sincérité
et utiliser la sincérité comme un joker
pour se dispenser de tenir compte de la
souffrance de l'autre
utilisez la sincérité pour se soulager
donc il y a parfois dans la
revendication de sincérité un élément
d'égoïsme
le fait de se dire que l'autre doit
toujours se tenir prêt à entendre la
vérité que j'ai à lui dire
mais dans les faits ça marche pas comme
ça
être sincère entièrement sincère ça a un
coup
un coup pour celui qui reçoit notre
sincérité
donc ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que la sincérité
est aussi un bon moyen pour ne pas
assumer certains de contraintes
aussi on va prendre un exemple
imaginons que vous soyez marié marié
depuis plusieurs années
vous étiez très amoureux de votre
partenaire au début de la relation
c'était l'époque de l'amour passion
l'époque de la folie et de l'insouciance
et puis la routine a commencé à
s'installer
vous vous êtes installé ensemble vous
avez eu des enfants
vos rapports sexuels ont commencé à
s'espacer
et votre vie de couple n'est plus aussi
trépidante casser début
bon la vie quoi
si vous êtes sincère avec vous-même
vous allez vous dire je ne suis plus
heureux avec cette personne
je m'ennuie avec cette personne
je ne l'aime plus
et si je ne l'aime plus je n'ai plus de
raison de rester avec
supposons que vous rencontriez quelqu'un
d'autre
une personne plus belle ou plus jeune ou
plus intéressantes peu importe vous
allez vous dire
je ne peux plus me mentir à moi-même
je ne peux plus faire semblant
je n'aime plus mon partenaire
donc si je suis sincère avec moi-même je
dois le quitter
je lui dois la vérité
je lui dois d'être sincère
ce que nous dit Jacques élu c'est qu'à
ce moment-là la sincérité n'est qu'un
prétexte
un prétexte moral une caution morale
pour en réalité assouvir un désir
beaucoup moins noble
l'envie de quelqu'un d'autre
l'envie charnelle de quelqu'un d'autre
au fond j'utilise l'argument de la
sincérité pour justifier le fait que je
veux satisfaire un désir
alors là beaucoup d'entre vous je pense
risque de ne pas être d'accord
et de se dire bah non
si on n'aime plus la personne avec qui
on partage sa vie c'est normal de la
quitter
c'est même mieux de la quitter
parce qu'on ne reste pas avec quelqu'un
juste pour lui faire plaisir
à quoi bon
si on n'est pas heureux avec une
personne quel intérêt à rester avec elle
et bien effectivement
vous avez raison
il n'y a pas d'intérêt à rester avec
quelqu'un qu'on n'aime plus
ce que nous dit Jacques cellule c'est
que la sincérité est avant tout la Libye
autrement dit la Libye de l'égoïsme
bon alors déjà il faut garder à l'esprit
qui est nul écrit ce texte à une époque
où la notion d'engagement pour la vie
encore une réalité
ce qui n'est plus tout à fait le cas
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il y a plus de divorce que
de mariage
donc forcément l'engagement pour la vie
la fidélité pour la vie on va trouver sa
réac on va trouver ça vieux jeu
et pour Ulule ce n'est pas être vieux
jeu que de penser ça
de penser que quand on s'engage dans une
union on sent désengage pas à la
première paire de face qui passe
sinon à quoi bon s'unir
on le sait qu'il y a des paires de
fesses un peu partout
on le découvre pas subitement le
lendemain du mariage
on sait que la passion peut s'étioler
avec le temps
ça non plus on le découvre pas
et si on le découvre
il faut l'assumer
nul n'est censé ignorer la loi du désir
donc ici pour le coup on a une totale
opposition avec ça
Sartre disait que le mariage était un
acte par lequel on transformait l'amour
en contrat mais que par définition
l'amour ne peut pas faire l'objet d'un
contrat
parce que l'amour ne se contrôle pas
parce qu'on ne peut pas s'engager à
aimer quelqu'un
le contrat relève de la morale
l'amour relève du sentiment
et un sentiment est indifférent à la
morale
la réponse de Jacques élule c'est de
dire que le sentiment abandon
on peut tout justifier par le sentiment
quelqu'un m'a fait souffrir je le tue
pour me venger c'est un sentiment
d'accord c'est un sentiment
mais que fait-on de la raison
que fait-on de la maîtrise de soi
de la retenue
c'est quand même possible de se retenir
nous ne sommes pas obligés d'être
gouverné par le sentiment
ou par le désir
ou par l'impulsion
donc derrière la logique de la sincérité
avec soi-même il y a autre chose
il y a la logique du désir individuel
la logique tu refus de la contrainte
je me dis sincère parce qu'être sincères
me permet de légitimer le fait de suivre
mon désir
et donc de ne rien devoir à personne
si ton Jack est nul
ce devoir de sincérité m'oblige à dire à
ma femme que je ne l'aime plus sans me
préoccuper de l'effet que cela lui fera
continuer à vivre avec elle en faisant
semblant ne serait-ce pas une affreuse
hypocrisie me contraindre à quoi que ce
soit hypocrisie obéir à une valeur
hypocrisie observer une morale qui en
effet m'empêcherait de faire ou d'être
ce que j'ai envie de faire ou d'être
hypocrisie ne pas dire aussitôt son
opinion pour la réfléchir la contrôler
hypocrisie l'important c'est de ne
jamais faire semblant d'être soi-même
donc vous aurez bien noté le caractère
ironique de ce passage
et Ludes critique ici le discours qui
sous couvert de sincérité prône en
réalité la franchissement à l'égard de
toutes les contraintes
parce que si être sincère c'est faire
tout ce qu'on a envie de faire et dire
tout ce qui nous passe par la tête
quelle est la différence entre la
sincérité et l'impulsivité
sincérité et l'insensibilité à l'autre
on peut appeler ça de l'hypocrisie mais
alors toute la vie en société est
hypocrisie
d'ailleurs c'est ce que disait Rousseau
pour Rousseau dès lors qu'on vit en
société dès lors qu'on instaure des
règles d'interactions et de coexistence
on cesse d'être soi-même
en cesse d'être vrai
on devient poli
parce que poli ça vient de police qui
veut dire la cité
mais là encore est-ce qu'on n'est pas en
train de redécouvrir la lune
parce qu'on sait très bien que la vie en
société repose sur des règles
sur des usages
on le sait qu'il faut dire bonjour s'il
vous plaît merci au revoir
est-ce que l'hypocrisie ce ne serait pas
plutôt de faire semblant de le découvrir
pour s'en offusquer
est-ce que l'hypocrisie ce ne serait pas
de prétendre que ces règles nous
empêchent d'être nous-mêmes alors que si
ces règles n'étaient pas respectées par
les autres on serait le premier à s'en
plaindre
c'est un peu facile
ceux qui dénoncent l'hypocrisie sociale
sont souvent les premières rouspétés
parce que la guystère de la Poste ne
leur a pas dit bonjour
donc il faut choisir
ce que nous dit Jacques cellule c'est
tout simplement qu'on appelle hypocrisie
les contraintes qu'on a pas envie de
respecter
c'était donc pas la sincérité que
critique Jacqueline
ce qui critique c'est l'utilisation de
l'argument de la sincérité comme
justification morale du refus des
contraintes
on se cache derrière l'argument de la
sincérité on se drape dans cette vertu
pour ne pas admettre que ce qui nous
motive profondément c'est uniquement la
satisfaction de nos désirs personnels
et que dans cette recherche de
satisfaction la sincérité me permet de
ne pas me soucier de l'autre et donc de
ne pas faire d'effort
vous savez c'est comme quand on dit je
suis comme ça
je suis susceptible je suis autoritaire
je suis jaloux oui mais je suis comme ça
donc si tu es comme ça ça change tout
comme si le fait de dire je suis comme
ça
annuler le travers en question
comme si le fait d'assumer ses défauts
rendait ses défauts moins gênants
mais dire je suis comme ça ce n'est pas
être sincère
c'est dire je ne veux pas changer
c'est dire accepte et tais-toi
donc encore une fois si le but de la
sincérité c'est de légitimer le fait de
ne pas tenir compte de l'autre qu'est-ce
que la sincérité si ce n'est le paravent
de l'égoïsme
derrière sa critique de la prétendue
sincérité ce que critique jacquelule
c'est la conception de l'être humain
comme pure spontanéité
la modernité nous avons dû le concept de
spontanéité en en faisant une valeur
positive
or la spontanéité n'est pas une valeur
en soi
si la spontanéité est une valeur
positive cela signifie que tous nos
efforts de rétentionultionnelle devienne
superflu
je peux céder à toutes mes envies
puisque la spontanéité mais autorise
bâiller au nez de quelqu'un qui m'ennuie
c'est de la spontanéité
mettre une gifle à quelqu'un qui m'agace
c'est la spontanéité
la spontanéité c'est l'abolition de la
maîtrise de soi
autrement dit c'est l'abolition de ce
qui fait l'essence même de l'humanité à
savoir la possibilité de s'élever
au-delà de ses pulsions
de s'élever tout court
la modernité prône la spontanéité
elle prône l'authenticité
mais cette authenticité ne désigne plus
l'accord entre ces actes et ses pensées
elle désigne l'accord entre ces actes et
ses pulsions
et cette promotion de la spontanéité
s'est opéré à travers un renversement de
la définition du concept de liberté qui
autrefois désignait la capacité de
maîtriser ses pulsions et qui
aujourd'hui désigne la possibilité
d'assouvir ses pulsions
renversement total
et dans le même temps où la spontanéité
a été érigée en valeur positive
la maîtrise de soi est devenue un objet
de dénigrement
la maîtrise de soi ce serait la rigidité
l'austérité
ce serait ne pas savoir lâcher prise
or la modernité nous dit qu'il faut
lâcher prise
qu'il faut se lâcher
et entendez bien cette expression
se lâcher
généralement quand on lâche quelque
chose ou quelqu'un c'est pas très
positif
quand on lâche ça tombe
peut-être y a-t-il derrière le fait de
se lâcher
quelque chose qui mène à la chute
la modernité a fait de nous des
consommateurs
autrement dit des êtres de désir
uniquement soucieux de maximiser notre
intérêt et notre plaisir
la modernité nous a réduit à notre
dimension corporelle
et être sincère dans un monde de
consommateur c'est faire passer pour une
vertu le fait de céder à toutes ces
impulsions
le fait de suivre ses tripes
il n'y a pas de mérite à suivre ces
tripes
tous les animaux en sont capables
mais sauf que l'être humain
ce n'est pas un animal comme les autres
c'est un animal qui a la capacité de
dire non à ses impulsions
de les réfréner
l'homme est un animal symbolique
c'est-à-dire qu'il est capable de passer
par la médiation du langage pour nommer
les choses
et nommer les choses c'est les maîtriser
parce que dès lors qu'on nomme les
choses on les tient à distance
on peut les penser et réfléchir les
théories
c'est pas pour rien qu'en grec ancien
logos signifiait à la fois parole et
esprit
le Logos c'est le verbe
quand on s'abandonne immédiatement à ses
désirs
on cesse d'utiliser le verbe comme un
intermédiaire entre nous et le monde
on devient les êtres impulsifs
des êtres primitifs
et le langage ne sert alors plus qu'à
développer un discours de justification
du fait de céder à nos impulsions
c'est une défaite
la critique que fait Jacques elûle de la
prétendue sincérité est en réalité une
critique du monde contemporain comme
civilisation de la pulsion
la pulsion nous ramène à scoplaton nous
met l'épium
le bas ventre
or le bas-ventre c'est ce qui nous
rattache à notre animalité et au-delà à
la matérialité
la matière c'est la sphère des besoins
des besoins alimentaires des besoins
sexuels des besoins physiologiques
autrement dit des besoins animaux
c'est pour cette raison que le corps a
été historiquement dévalorisé par
rapport à l'esprit
parce que le corps c'est ce que nous
avons en commun avec les bêtes
les bêtes aussi ont des besoins
physiologiques
les bêtes aussi se reproduisent
sauf que nous nous avons la capacité de
ne pas être seulement des bêtes
nous avons la capacité de privilégier la
raison par rapport à la pulsion
ça fait quand même une différence
et c'est pour ça que nous avons inventé
la culture
la civilisation
être civilisé c'est préserver le champ
social de la pulsion
raison pour laquelle en société on ne
fait pas certaines choses
on expose pas certaines choses
on expose pas tout ce qui est lié à
notre dimension animale
à commencer par nos organes
reproducteurs
on les cache
quand Adam et Eve goûte le fruit défendu
leur toute première réaction est de se
rendre compte qu'ils sont nus
et il se cachent parce qu'ils en ont
honte
on dissimule les organes sexuels parce
que ce sont les organes de la
reproduction et de la déjection
autrement dit ce sont les organes de
l'animalité
de la physiologie pure
à l'époque du classicisme au théâtre il
était interdit de manger sur scène
parce que manger c'est un besoin animal
et on ne représentait pas l'animalité
c'était littéralement obscène
exclu de la scène
exclu du champ de la représentation
de même que l'acte sexuel
l'acte sexuel nous rattache à la
primitivité de la matière
le corps nous rattache à la matière
alors que l'Esprit nous en libère
on s'élève par l'esprit
si les métiers intellectuels sont
socialement valorisés par rapport au
métier manuel ce n'est pas pour rien
c'est parce que les métiers
intellectuels sont les métiers de
l'esprit tandis que les métiers manuels
sont les métiers du corps
c'est ça la raison profonde de la
valorisation de l'esprit
l'esprit ce sont les ailes du corps
et privés de ces ailes le corps ne peut
plus s'élever
freud disait que pour faire société il
fallait en rabattre sur ses pulsions
raison pour laquelle tous les individus
sociaux sont pour lui des névrosées
nous sommes tous des névrosés parce que
nous sommes tous dans l'obligation de
réprimer nos pulsions
la névrose c'est la tension intérieure
issue du combat entre la pulsion et la
loi
la loi m'empêche d'assouvir ma pulsion
sans tenir compte d'autrui
c'est parce que je m'empêche que je peux
cohabiter avec autrui
pour en revenir à ellule l'idée c'est de
dire qu'en cédant à la spontanéité
nous renonçons à ce qui fait notre
humanité
car nous renonçons à la médiation de
l'esprit et à la liberté qui en découle
la matière c'est le domaine de la
contrainte
il n'y a pas de liberté dans la matière
la matière est régie par des lois
des lois déterministes
la loi de la causalité la loi de la
gravité
comme le corps est régi par la loi de la
pulsion
l'esprit et le domaine de la liberté
parce que l'esprit le domaine de
l'émancipation à l'égard de la matière
être conscient de ses pulsions c'est ce
qui nous permet de ne pas y être soumis
de ne pas nous y abandonner
de choisir
quand on cède à ses désirs on cède au
déterminisme de la matière
on n'est pas libre on obéit
on suit ses désirs
rien n'est plus faux que l'idée selon
laquelle suivre ses désirs serait un
acte de liberté
obéir à ses désirs être gouverné par ses
désirs
c'est au contraire retomber dans
l'animalité
dans l'automatisme aveugle de la pulsion
la critique de la modernité que nous
livre Jacques ellule
c'est une critique de la facilité
il est plus facile de descendre les
escaliers que de les monter
il est plus facile de se laisser aller
que de s'élever
la sincérité justifie la spontanéité
et en justifiant la spontanéité elle
justifie l'inertie
elle justifie de rester ce qu'on est
plutôt que de chercher à s'améliorer
elle fait passer pour une valeur
la destitution de toutes les valeurs
je cite
le dessin est admirable fuir
l'hypocrisie cesser enfin ce jeu affreux
ou se sont conclus nos pères voire
clairement les choses en face se
rencontrer soi-même ne pas ruser avec
les faits ni avec les évidences exercer
cette rigueur qui nous porte à être
toujours d'une seule pièce de façon que
l'extérieur de nous-mêmes soit conforme
à l’intérieur ne pas en définitive avoir
un corps partagé qui ne serait pas
séduit par un si haut désir par une scie
pure expression je m'ennuie maintenant
dans cette compagnie j'ai envie de
bâiller je bâille sans retenue au nez de
mes voisins je suis sincère avec
moi-même la femme que j'ai épousée ne me
plaît plus ne m'excite plus je lui dis
tout crûment et je la quitte c'est de la
simple honnêteté j'ai besoin de façon
urgente de cet argent que je vois sur la
table il n'y a aucun doute que tout mon
être est tendu vers lui je le prends il
s'agit de sincérité toute pure car telle
est cette sincérité il ne s'agit certes
pas du soi-même que je veux devenir du
modèle que je me suis tracé auquel il
faudrait me hausser et dont le reflet se
projetterait dans mon actualité non
certes nous serions ici dans le domaine
de l'exécrable de voir de l'obligation
de la contrainte inacceptable pour ses
esprits libres car bien entendu cela
suppose que l'autre n'existe pas que je
me refuse à considérer les effets de ce
que je dis sur l'autre de ce que je suis
à son égard que je le blesse et que je
le tue par ma sincérité qu'importe il y
a un choix parfaitement inconscient
d’ailleurs et de ce fait suspect et
méprisable entre l'amour de l'autre et
l'amour de soi car cette fameuse
sincérité n'est rien de plus qu'amour de
soi je me passe mes envies je suis mes
plaisirs j'obéis à mes instincts au
niveau le plus superficiel c'est le
muscle au niveau le plus profond c'est
l'assassins spirituel quand monsieur
Sartre change d'opinion politique comme
de chemises la sincérité envers lui-même
exige qu'il éjacule aussitôt ce que ces
trips cérébrale ont produit et il
clament avec ferveur la conviction du
moment pour puis contre puis pour l'URSS
ou le PC ou le socialisme etc qu'importe
les faits sur les milliers de jeunes
gens qui le suivent dans ces virevoltes
dans ses palinody qu'importe qu'il est
désoriente qui provoque des crises de
conscience qu'importe bien plus que par
ses virages brusques qu'ils suivent il
les prépare à devenir un troupeau à
propagande suivant n'importe quel chef
après ce prestigieux philosophe il est
sincère avec lui-même la situation est
simple très simple il s'agit de
justification une fois de plus il s'agit
de vivre sans contrainte et sans tutelle
en suivant ce qu'il y a de plus
élémentaire de plus animal ou de plus
méprisable dans l'homme en suivant le
plus facile et le plus lâche mais comme
on n'est pas des bêtes hein quand même
il faut se prouver à soi-même qu'on a
des raisons de vivre ainsi de sa Vachir
et de se laisser aller il faut se passer
à lanterne magique et se référer aux
grands auteurs parce qu'on a de
l'instruction il faut surtout se sentir
la conscience en paix alors on utilise
le coût de la sincérité
notre époque nous dit Jacques cellule
est une époque d'imposture
parce que nous appelons liberté ce qui
n'est rien d'autre que la soumission à
notre animalité
et nous appelons sincérité ce qui n'est
rien d'autre que le refus d'évoluer
les sens de l'être humain c'est la
perfectibilité
c'est-à-dire la capacité de s'améliorer
vous-même qui m'écoutait vous n'êtes
plus la même personne aujourd'hui
qu'il y a 10 ans
qu'il y a un an
qu'il y a une semaine
parce que chaque expérience nous modifie
parce que nous possédons une conscience
grâce à laquelle nous pouvons être
attentif à ce que nous vivons
et transformer notre expérience en
enseignement
le propre de l'être humain c'est de ne
pas être condamné à rester ce qu'il est
et cette capacité devient une
responsabilité
notre responsabilité
celle de tenir compte de l'existence de
l'autre
celle de nous rendre compte
que nous avons besoin de l'autre
car si l'humanité avait vécu dans
l'indifférence à l'autre
nous ne serions tout simplement pas là
pour en témoigner
je vous remercie
[Musique]